so the one thing that so they always  talk about in the U.S that Planned  Parenthood is for women like that's like  that's one of the major organizations  that support women but a lot of people  don't know that it was founded by a  eugenicist so the the point of this  question is that 80 of planned  parenthoods are located within walking  distance of minority communities in the  U.S and the founder of Planned  Parenthood referred to black people as  weeds that needed to be exterminated and  that and they're they're actually doing  it to this day because the black  community in the U.S has a 50 birth rate  and the black population will be doubled  today if it wasn't for Planned  Parenthood which is the number one  leading provider of abortions in the U.S